the only heat the only warmth in this
city comes now from the fires made from
the debris of the homes where these
people once lived survivors cling onto
the hope that somehow their loved ones
may still be alive under the rubble for
Hassan gun tech in that means his wife
three children
and mother-in-law
we don't need food Aid what we need is
technical Aid I need my three kids to be
rescued even if only one of my kids
survived it will be a hope for me to
continue living otherwise there's no
point to keep on living I don't know
what I'll do who will call me dad during
eids
Street after Street
District after District it took just two
minutes of the earthquake to cause all
this destruction
it's the most devastating quake in
Turkey since 1939 building regulations
have come a long way since then but
enforcing them is a different matter
before the last presidential and
parliamentary elections the government
granted amnesty for building code
violations fining companies instead
now a million people are homeless in
Antarctica most of the city of four
hundred thousand has been destroyed the
challenge now for the government is
trying to stop this catastrophe turning
into a Public Health crisis the air is
thick with smoke and dust there is no
sanitation people are still living on
the streets and there are bodies still
under the rubble that is why there is
such an urgent need to get people away
from the disaster site and into
temporary tented accommodation
there are now fewer visible rescue
operations here
unfortunately my country which I love so
much has failed they're so disorganized
and can't work at all it's the sixth day
in every day two different teams take
part in the rescue I haven't seen any
officials here neither from the
government nor from the mayor's office I
don't want to see them anyway they don't
come here because they know we don't
want to see them
this is what's left of the home Hassan
had made with his family
the unimaginable pain of losing a child
or loved one is being felt by tens of
thousands of people in Turkey this week
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera and Takia